[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning a last resort the words of a
prime minister desperate to avoid
another lockdown in england and today he
will reveal his plans to try to do just
that whilst keeping covered at bay over
the winter we'll be bringing you the
first details of the plan just starting
to emerge and i'll speak to the vaccines
minister and dean zahi shortly plus
jabs for 12 year olds get the green
light but there are some concerns over
consent and exactly how it will be
decided if a child can overrule a parent
who isn't in favor also on the show
hey stop hitting the dog hold him
could this be the bravest dog in the
world police dog stark took down a
suspected criminal before being hit 20
times with a machete but he hang on
we'll be meeting him at around about
half past dates
and
we will be speaking at a man you may
well be familiar with he's just
completed the coldest swim on earth
lewis pugh is his name and he'll be
joining us at half past night it is
tuesday the 14th of september
winter warmer the prime minister is
expected to reveal a bonfire of some
coded restrictions alongside boosted
jabs for all over 50s but this warning
from one top doctor
what's clear
is that the vaccination program on its
own is not um showing itself to be
sufficient
and i'll be here live in downing street
where that covered winter plan will be
on the agenda for cabinet which boris
johnson will be holding shortly
12 to 15 year olds will be offered
covert jabs in england but there are
concerns over consent here's what the
health secretary told this program just
last week
as long as we believe that the child is
competent enough to make this decision
then the child's will will prevail
baseless unviable and potentially
unlawful prince andrew's lawyer hits out
over claims of sexual assault against
the duke of york
our climate change correspondent reports
from the rainforest in gabon as a new
warning suggests that millions could die
in extreme temperatures if world leaders
can't agree over greenhouse gases
gabon is one of the few countries on
earth that absorbs more carbon than it
emits it's why this whole region is
crucial to the battle against climate
change
and why what happens here will matter
far beyond national borders
spyware alert apple issues an emergency
software update after devices became
vulnerable to attack without the user
even having to click on anything
game set and match made in heaven as
emma radekam joins a star-studded cast
of celebs dressed to impress at new
york's met gallop
[Music]
morning all
today the prime minister will reveal his
plans to fight covert over winter
at the same time as relaxing as many
restrictions as possible he says future
lockdowns will be a last resort but some
powers will remain up his sleeve i plan
to offer booster jabs to all over 50s is
expected to take center stage after the
news that jabs for 12 to 15 year olds
have had the green light the chair of
the british medical association has told
us though that vaccines alone just
aren't enough the pm's also expected to
relax some other restrictions such as
scrapping or simplifying some of the
travel measures that may well also be
announced the vaccines minister will be
on the show shortly about first our
chief political correspondent john craig
has this report
boris johnson is getting ready for
winter and a possible new wave of covid
his plan booster jabs for over 50s and
flu vaccinations
he'll say further lockdowns in england
are a last resort
and in an expanding vaccine program the
pm believes he has the tool he needs but
he's warning the pandemic is far from
over but thanks to our phenomenal
vaccine program new treatments and
testing we're able to live with the
virus without significant restrictions
on our freedoms
government scientists are nervous
however claiming the covid risk remains
real anybody who believes
that the big risk of covert is now in
all it's all in the past and actually
it's too late to be making a difference
has not understood where we're going to
head as we go into autumn and winter
where there will continue to be
challenges it will continue to be
pressure on the nhs
the booster scheme due to start later
this month will mean a third vaccine
dose for millions of older people to
slow winter infections with over 80s and
vulnerable people first followed by all
over 50s by christmas
but with case numbers climbing doctors
are calling for more than just jabs
what's clear
is that the vaccination program on its
own is not um showing itself to be
sufficient because in spite of
vaccinating more and more of the
population we're still seeing
significant increases in people becoming
seriously ill and admitted to hospital
many on ventilators and many more dying
the prime minister however says the uk
must learn to live with the virus and
he's scrapping some emergency coveted
rules introduced last year
but some powers are being kept in
reserve measures such as the compulsory
wearing of face masks and mandatory
vaccination passports
that is likely to provoke an angry
backlash from many conservative mps
the pm may be adamant that he won't
impose another lockdown in england but
he won't rule it out either
john craig sky news
and we are joined once again on the
programme by the vaccines minister nadim
zahari mrs howie really good to see you
this morning um
and it does feel having dipped my toe
into social media this morning seen some
concern seeing plenty of misinformation
it feels like we all need to take a few
deep breaths this morning because we are
talking about vaccinating children can
you just repeat the justification that
was given to the public yesterday by the
chief medical officer why do we feel it
is necessary
for 12 to 15 year olds to receive a
vaccine
yes absolutely good morning neil so uh
the joint committee on vaccination
immunization who have relied upon and
have they have delivered throughout the
vaccine deployment program have been on
your show many times um beginning uh
back last year when we launched with the
advisor bionic vaccine on the 8th of
december
the jcbi
looked at the clinical
impact on 12 15 year olds and
came down on the side that that actually
being vaccinated is marginally better
but not enough to
recommend a universal vaccination
program they recommended that the chief
medical officers of england wales
scotland northern ireland
look at
the
other public health and mental health
impacts on children not on the wider
population on those 12 15 year olds
they reported yesterday and they have
unanimously all four chief medical
officers england scotland wales and
northern ireland have recommended that
we offer a one
uh dose of the pfizer biontic vaccine to
12 year olds now the way we will do that
is and we've accepted that advice is
through the school age immunization
service which has been doing uh
vaccination of children for many many
years very well-versed doing this so
clinicians will lead on this in school
schools
will contact parents in the usual way
that they do and will require consent
parental consent uh of course and this
is voluntary there is no stigmatization
of any parent or
anyone who may choose not to have the
vaccine although i have to say when we
offered the vaccine last month the 16
and 17 year olds they came forward um in
the past month in their droves and their
numbers because they realized that how
important it is to protect themselves
and of course they've seen firsthand the
damage that the covert pandemic has
done to mental health and of course
through schools as well
but but just just to go back to the
rationale for this part of the concern
as i understand it from parents who've
expressed concern is that we have in
essence you know clinical advice
being given for non-clinical purposes we
have we have doctors advising 12 to 15
year olds to follow a medical process a
vaccination
for reasons which don't seem to have a
grounding in the clinical side and
that's worrying people
and that's really important to uh sort
of
try and flesh out for your viewers the
chief medical officers
were asked the jcbi the joint committee
actually recommended that we ask the
chief medical officers
we asked them they also consulted with
the royal colleges of pediatrics uh the
royal college of gps and of course the
jcpi were in the room uh to look at the
mental health impact on those 12 year
olds at the public health impact on the
12 15 years not on the greater uh sort
of good of society it's actually for
those um uh 12 to 15 year olds the jcbi
uh were only sort of looking at what
they are narrowly qualified to look at
which is why they made the
recommendation that we should also ask
the chief medical officers they have now
come back to us and they recommend
the offer of a single dose uh for 12
year olds with parental consent so that
is what we'll be going ahead and doing
it's been a very just honest incent
point sorry
just on the consent prime minister we
we've really got a finite amount of time
this morning i'm really keen to kind of
get through as many questions as
possible on the consent point how will
that be how will that be administered
again of course and a bit of
disinformation on social media this
morning i mean isn't it the case that
you know 12 to 15 year olds can you know
right now consent to other forms of of
medical treatment where their parents
perhaps have a different view
so the uh consent process the school-age
immunization service
have are really really well equipped to
do they've been doing it for years for
children's vaccination in schools so
children will have a leaflet that they
can share with their parents and of
course we'll have a consent form
that will go to them either
electronically or in some schools
physically to their parents and the
parents will then read all the
information
have to give consent if the child is to
be vaccinated on the very rare
occasions where there is a difference
opinion of opinion between the parent
and the 12 to 15 year old
where the parent for example doesn't
want to give consent but the 12 to 15
year old wants to have the vaccine then
the first step is the clinician of the
school immunization
service will bring the parent and the 12
to 15 year old the child together to see
whether they can reach consent if that
is not possible then if the child is
deemed to be competent and this has been
around since the 80s for all
vaccination programs for example in
schools if the child is deemed to be
competent the gillig competence as it's
referred to
then the child can have the vaccine but
these are very rare
um
occasions and it is very important to
remember that the school
age immunization service is incredibly
well equipped to deal with this
clinicians are very well versed in
delivering vaccinations to 12 year olds
in schools
sure
let's talk though about about the winter
plan and this was something we explored
with with your colleague therese coffee
yesterday it is absolutely fair to say
isn't it that despite the the clear
inclination to avoid lockdowns to avoid
reintroduction mandatory face masks
social distancing and so on clearly you
don't want to do it but those options
remain in the arsenal don't they
so the
non-pharmaceutical interventions the
npis the dreaded mpis were our only
weapon against the virus before the
vaccines came along the vaccines now are
are the the prime way we have been able
to manage this virus and there will
continue to be as the prime minister
will set out later today as will the
secretary of state uh make a statement
to parliament they will sure sure but
let's again we're really pushing for
time lockdown remains an option doesn't
it social mass
social distancing mask wedding it all
remains an option it's just because the
prime minister will be saying you know
the pandemic is far from over but you
know we are able to live with the virus
without significant restrictions on our
freedoms i'm just wondering where the
tipping point is that would lead to for
example
lockdown being brought back in and so on
so lockdowns would be an absolutely last
resort what we're trying to
do at the moment neil is to transition
this virus from pandemic to endemic
through a
massive vaccination program we know the
vaccines have saved over 112 000 lives
24 million infections we're about to
embark on a massive booster
campaign uh and of course a flu
vaccination program because i am
concerned about flu we haven't had much
flu circulating anywhere in the world
and in a bad year you know we could lose
up to 25 000 people to flee
so the combination of the booster
campaign for covet which the prime
minister will say more about today as
will the secretary of state in terms of
the uh jcvi final advice which we have
now uh received and uh accepted the
interim advice which they gave us on the
30th of june helped us to plan
so planning has been well underway
to be able to i hope come back on your
program and break the record that we set
in the first vaccination program because
we have a massive task ahead to
effectively protect the most vulnerable
uh with a third booster
as well as of course we're already doing
the immunosuppressed uh with as part of
their primary uh vaccine treatment uh
sorry minister the reason i push on this
is at times this week it does feel like
the messaging from government has been
in different places at the weekend you
know that's an end no vaccine passports
the following day we find out that they
remain on the table telling the prime
minister incredibly optimistic but at
the same time suggesting that there are
circumstances in which as you've just
conceded we could go back into lockdown
i mean it's a little bit early in the
year to be asking these kind of
questions i will concede but you can't
for example guarantee right now that
we'll all be able to spend christmas
with our families can you
so look the important thing to remember
is as we embark on the winter months the
virus have an in in built advantage
whether it be flu or the covered virus
as griswitty set out yesterday it would
be uh uh full-hearted suggest that you
know this thing's already transitioned
from pandemic to endemic that is the
direction that we're taking
a massive booster campaign a really fit
for purpose surveillance variant
surveillance system a really fit for
purpose test and trace system that is
where we
think we will be able to end up we're
confident that we have the
infrastructure in place to deliver on
this but of course look we we have to
have contingency planning there is uh
you know
all the time uh more information coming
in on how the virus is behaving
winter hasn't you know gives the virus
an inbuilt advantage boosters reduce
that advantage by you know hopefully uh
uh taking the most vulnerable out of
harm's way of the fight i understand all
that i understand all that minister i
i'm really i'm really not looking for
some kind of gotcha moment here all that
i'm trying to kind of to flesh out is
the idea that we are not out of the
woods in terms of covert even if things
go as well as you expect you know there
remains the possibility however likely
or unlikely that we could see ourselves
returning to you know public health
responses the likes of which we have
seen you know in the recent past
so again i just repeat for your viewers
um the non-pharmaceutical interventions
the lockdowns were our only tool that is
no longer true that we have the vaccines
we have the test and trace system we
have the surveillance the various
surveillance system we have the public
health advice which people followed of
all ages you know really really
diligently which has allowed us to take
step four to reopen uh our economy
and the booster campaign with flu will
help
basically protect the most vulnerable as
we transition i hope this virus and i
can come back on your program and say to
you after winter's over hand on heart we
are the you know one of the leading
major economies of the world to
demonstrate how you transition the virus
from pandemic to endemic and then deal
with it on an annual basis through the
inoculation the vaccination program we
will we will all be keeping our fingers
crossed that that is the case i i do
wonder though what your advice would be
to colleagues within your party who are
openly expressing skepticism about one
key aspect of all of this the
vaccination of 12 to 15 year olds marcus
fish tweeted this sorry to have to say
it but the chief medical officer chris
whittie does not deserve the confidence
of the country in deciding to vaccinate
teenagers without good clinical reason
his words he the chief medical officer
should resign what would you say to mr
fish this morning
well all i would say is that um both the
jcbi who in their guide and said look um
it is marginally more beneficial to be
vaccinated the 12 15 healthy 12 15 year
olds it's well worth reminding
your audience that we've been
vaccinating cloth teen year olds who are
more vulnerable
as per the jcbi advice the jcbi advice
also
said that we should consult the four
chief medical officers and they have
unanimously come back this is not just
chris whittie this is all four chief
medical officers of england scotland
wales and northern ireland to give us
the advice that we should make the
vaccine available uh two twelve 12th
funerals who are healthy and for their
parents to consent and that is exactly
what we will be doing
a good point on which to conclude uh
minister good to see you this morning
thanks for being with us
thank you
now one leading scientist has told sky
news
that there is a clear possibility that
the nhs could face a serious situation
over the winter epidemiologist professor
mark woolhouse of the university of
edinburgh says two sets of figures
helped to highlight the point
our hospital admissions for coronavirus
are as you can see creeping up and
especially so
excuse me for the over 85s the rate of
admissions for people aged over 65 has
more than doubled over the past two
months however the number of
hospitalizations and deaths in the third
way are low relative to the second wave
at case rates will have risen in all
four countries of the uk since june
and have reached record highs as you can
see in scotland around about 795 people
testing positive in the week to the 8th
of september
now let's take a look at some of the
latest covered data
there were 30
825 new cases of coronavirus reported in
the last 24-hour period a further 61
people have died taking the total number
of people who died within 28 days of a
positive test to 134 261.
almost 15 000 first doses of a covered
vaccine have been given while more than
52 000 people received their second dose
in total
just over 44 million people are now
fully vaccinated
uh just a little bit of breaking news to
bring you that you are seeing in the
bottom of your screen during our
interview with the vaccines minister at
the number of job vacancies in june to
august 2021 has risen over 1 million for
the first time since records began and
is now
249 000 above its pre-pandemic january
to march 2020 level at more on that a
little bit later but still to come on
the programme as we've been discussing
the pm to set out his plans later on
on how he's going to be keeping covert
out this winter we'll be speaking with a
clinical microbiologist at half seven
what does labour make of the
government's winter covered plants we'll
be hearing from the shadow economics
retreat to the treasury patent garden at
five past eight
and at quarter to nine we'll be speaking
to the 23 year old who started her own
club after finding out that her friends
were excluding her from social events
prince andrew's lawyer says sexual
assault claims against the duke of york
are baseless unviable and potentially
unlawful he'll be speaking at a hearing
in the united states as our royal
correspondent rhiannon miltz reports
for six years we've seen this photograph
now for the first time we've heard from
both their lawyers
prince andrews legal team telling the
judge in new york the abuse allegations
are baseless non-viable and potentially
unlawful those acting for virginia du
frey insisting their case against him
has been effectively served after she
claimed she was sexually abused by him
three
alternatives lisa times represents some
of jeffrey epstein's victims and says
the judge has a number of ways he could
speed up the process
in many cases where i'm trying to serve
a high-profile person and i do a lot of
these cases the judge will give us an
alternative so that people can't just
continue to hide behind gates and walls
and fly out of the country
and i think those alternatives are
available in the uk as well
a document filed just hours before the
telephone court hearing confirmed prince
andrew's team would be challenging how
the papers were served
andrew bretler who's represented
hollywood stars on rape allegations told
the judge they have already referred it
to the high court in london
and said their case partly hangs on
another private settlement made by
virginia du frey that they believe
protects the duke and others from any
compensation claims
lawyer alan dershowitz is another of
those individuals
the release was cited in the dismissal
of the case against me it precludes
anybody who was covered by the release
from being sued by virginia goofy
virginia got her money she's gotten over
five million dollars she's built a
beautiful home and in exchange for the
money
that she has received she signed a
release she's bound by that
release duprey's team whose private
investigators served papers here at the
prince's home in windsor have now been
given a week to make any more requests
or apply to the court to help
it's believed that prince andrew is
still in scotland where the queen is
also spending her summer break his
lawyers planning their next steps with
the clock ticking and a judge now
expecting answers
rhiannon mills sky news in windsor
experts are warning that 10 million
people could die every year from extreme
weather caused by climate change a new
report by the chatham house
international affairs group found that
if carbon emissions are not drastically
reduced by 2030 severe and life-changing
climate impacts will be locked in for
future generations the report's author
dr daniel quigen has said a glimmer of
hope still exists and that we could
avoid these impacts if world leaders
were to take action now
around about 10 million people or more
by the 2030s unfortunately are likely to
die outside now this is all you know
incredibly
sad and depressing um but just a glimmer
of hope does still exist obviously we're
running up to cop 26 and countries are
increasing their pledges
increasing their ambition but really we
need to see on the ground policy action
to drive down those emissions
commensurate with the targets and more
and well just after half past seven we
have a special report from our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
on the calls for funding in gabon to
protect the forests essential to
absorbing carbon emissions
and as we always do let's take a quick
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet at the top line showing how
the uk's power is being produced just 18
from renewables at the moment and the
next line shows you how much warmer the
earth is now than back in 1880 when
records began then the figure to just
how long scientists believe it will take
to reach the plus 1.5 degrees celsius
figure seen by many as a point of no
return for the planet and finally that
large statistic at the bottom there the
total amount of co2 emissions in
millions of tons
you can keep up to date with all the
stories affected by the climate on the
daily climate show right here live on
sky news every weekday at half past six
now apple has issued an emergency
software update after a flaw was found
which allows certain spyware to infect
some products including the iphone and
the mac without the user having to click
on anything that's guys jeremiah walker
joins us to give us a little bit more
detail on this incredibly worrying that
you don't even have to
do anything to become infected explain a
bit more
yeah exactly and i think that's why
apple has moved quite quickly to
update its software in order to stop
this zero clicks spyware so normally
you'd have to click on a link and an
email for example but with this specific
spyway you don't need to do that so the
flaw was found by researchers at the
university of toronto's uh citizen lab
and they had previously seen evidence of
zero-click spyware but this is the first
time they've been able to capture the
code in order to really work out exactly
how it works and they said that they
found evidence of it on the phone of an
uh saudi activist and they say they've
got high confidence that the israeli
security firm nso group was behind the
attack nso haven't confirmed or denied
it but they've just said that they will
continue to provide intelligence law
enforcement agencies around the world
with life-saving technologies to fight
terror and crime
jemima thanks very much indeed
now more than two-thirds of travel
companies are expected to make
redundancies when furlough comes to an
end later this month
a survey by abta estimates that around
100 000 jobs could be on the line the
group is calling for an overhaul to the
government's traffic light system for
travel including an end to the
widespread use of pcr covert tests to
help the sector recover
the prime minister's mother charlotte
johnson wall has died at the age of 79.
a portrait painter by trade should
suffer from parkinson's disease since
she was in her forties
she passed away suddenly and peacefully
in hospital according to a family
statement shared with the daily
telegraph
the family of missing british actor
tanya fear has confirmed that she has
been found safely by police
the actress was at last seen leaving her
apartment in los angeles on thursday the
9th of september in a statement on
twitter tanya's family say they're
relieved and grateful and they've
thanked the police and the public for
their help in finding her
picture story of the day this one at u.s
open winner emma radekan who spent last
night rubbing shoulders with hollywood
royalty at new york's iconic met gala
and if you've seen them before it is
always a typically flamboyant affair now
the 18 year olds looking very stunning i
have to say was invited to attend the
annual event by vogue's anna wintour
after winning saturday's final in
straight sets uh now despite her well
meteoric rise to fame she certainly
doesn't appear to be particularly over
odds at the event dressed in a two-piece
black and white off-the-shoulder number
that i'm reliably informed is from
chanel
she was joined on the red carpet by the
reality tv star kim kardashian yep
that's her
she made one of the biggest statements
at the gala the makeup mogul who turned
up with her estranged husband kanye west
was covered head to toe in a black
bodysuit with
only her hair visible
why
uh also making the headlines for his
show-stopping outfit the rapper and
singer-songwriter little naz x you need
to wait for the reveal here definition
of a fashion royalty
uh but once the cape comes off
he's hiding a golden outfit that looks
straight from star wars uh yeah rather
you than me mate meanwhile grammy winner
billy elish who co-hosted the event shed
those trademark baggy clothes for a huge
peach ball girl that she said was
inspired by marilyn monroe i think i can
see it actually
and rihanna while she's stolen the show
at the met many times in the past she
turned up late in this all-black jacket
this year
talking about cutting edge uh canadian
singer grimes came through swinging a
sword
down the red carpet complete with a
matching metallic face mask
uh and then we had the very definition
of a fashion statement uh the u.s
politician alexandra ocasio-cortez it
came supporting a dress demanding
that we tax the rich the medium is the
message she said about the dress
of course the perfect place to make that
point
the met gala organized by vogue
still to come on the programme exactly
where are all the jabs going i'll have
the very latest on what to expect from
the government's upcoming winter plan
announcement
today reveal his plans to fight covid
over winter at the same time as relaxing
as many of the restrictions as possible
the vaccines minister nadine sahabi told
me that lockdowns will only be
reintroduced as a last resort uh let's
speak to our political correspondent
kate mccann who's in downing street for
us this morning of course cabinet taking
place just a little bit later on um kate
just just just take us through that
which we learned from the vaccines
minister i mean pretty clearly options
remain on the table but they are doing
everything within their power to suggest
we are on the right trajectory to enjoy
if not an entirely normal winter than as
close to normal as possible
i certainly think that's the hope from
inside government but today and
certainly that interview with nadine
zahawu was all about a balancing act i
mean the crucial moment for me was when
you asked him about christmas you know
something that lots of people care about
people may still be starting to think
about it the weather's certainly putting
us in that frame of mind he couldn't
guarantee that people would be able to
celebrate christmas and it was actually
the way that he gave that answer you
know talking about vaccination programs
boosters being really the big hope that
the government thinks will make sure
that the nhs won't end up in crisis this
winter but he caveated that he talked
about how there would be the flu
infections that would come and
scientists really not knowing what the
data is going to look like and that'll
be one of the things today worth
watching out for in that press
conference with the prime minister and
his top scientific advisors those graphs
that we're so used to seeing the
trajectories the explanation of where we
might end up that will be one of the
most important parts of the messaging
that boris johnson is going to hope that
he can get right in the next couple of
months it will be that balancing act
though it will be about boosters about
vaccinations for children and of course
you asked about consent because children
12 to 15 year olds will be able to say
they want the vaccine even if their
parents don't want them to it sounds
complicated but the government is clear
that it does have a plan for that even
if it happens rarely
kate many thanks indeed
uh well let's speak now to ravi gupta
professor of clinical microbiology at
the cambridge institute uh also a member
of nurb tag the expert committee
advising the government on new and
emerging respiratory viruses today
though we should make it absolutely
clear speaking to us in a prefer in a
personal capacity professor gupta great
to have you
on the program this morning um
just got a general question to start
with
what would your response be to anyone
who suggests that we are out of the
woods as regards covid19 that's you know
the path to christmas and a happy time
with our families is entirely free of
potential danger
well i think we can see from the figures
uh that that you know we're still you
know nearing a thousand deaths a week uh
uh and and thousands of of hospitalized
patients who are challenging capacity in
our hospitals and of course making uh
care for non-coveted patients extremely
difficult as well because of the stretch
of the
uh of this of the staff that are in
those hospitals who have been under
pressure for 18 months now so we're uh
it's it's pretty clear i think from from
the data and from obviously uh
individual sources that we're not out of
the woods and and it doesn't bode well
for going into winter at all
and part of the reason for that of
course is that winter is the time that
traditionally respiratory infections
respiratory illnesses
really do start to place an increased
burden on
on a health cell even at the best of
times it seems to be pretty stretched
that's right and we should also remember
that respiratory diseases uh
uh also trigger uh things things like um
heart uh disease heart attacks um uh
abnormal rhythms so so
these infections are actually
responsible for a large number of
medical um uh
negative outcomes and so uh that's why
winter is traditionally a very difficult
time because especially vulnerable and
elderly people uh tend to be
the first victims of of uh respiratory
illness and all the complications that
arise from that
but given all of that then does it not
seem slightly strange that this is a
point at which the prime minister is
making a merit out of and we've
obviously got to to wait for his
statement this afternoon but appears to
be making a merit out of removing some
of the restrictions uh that have been
placed particularly as regards travel
quarantine uh and international
travelers coming here
yes so i think that if we cast our minds
back to july 19th uh
many scientists including myself were
saying that we need to take this slowly
because we have the transmission rates
are far too high to be removing all
restrictions and this will have a
knock-on effect in other words you can't
get it you know we won't get away with
this uh as a country uh moving into
winter and what we're seeing now is
really the result of of uh that advice
not being uh heeded and and now in a
position where we're even we're talking
about lockdowns again so i think that
you know with with the correct planning
this could have been avoided
and so it's a difficult position for
everyone involved
of course part of the part of the
announcement that we've had over the
past 24 hours relates to the vaccination
of 12 to 15 year olds you don't need to
go particularly far in social media to
to discover there's a degree of concern
among some parents about essentially a
clinical treatment to clinical advice
being given for what appear to be
non-clinical reasons what's your view on
that
well my view is that uh the
degree of uh uh
death and suffering uh
we are experiencing as a nation uh is is
immense and
therefore uh public health measures
aimed uh uh you know through vaccination
individuals is a valid um approach to
take in curb and transmission we have to
remember that the complications from the
vaccination extremely low in even in
children and in teenagers no matter what
people may might hear
and the risk of curvid19 of course is uh
is still there the risk of long covert
is still poorly understood but it is a
reality in the young children and this
could have debilitating impacts on them
and the second thing is we have we need
to remember that when people die uh then
the entire family is affected including
the young teenage the young children and
teenagers so
so so by doing nothing we are also um
putting those children through very
difficult times that will have knock-on
effects so i think overall the strategy
should be to vaccinate children as
quickly as possible to curb transmission
in the community
you mentioned a second ago professor
that the the data is perhaps not quite
there in terms of we don't certainly
don't fully understand long cover but
there is some data emerging that raises
concerns
about children i mean is that data set
in your opinion enough
that people should be just as a matter
of course vaccinating if they are
afforded the opportunity to do so
yes that's the on a personal level um my
children um would um you know i would i
would
put my children forward for vaccination
uh on the basis not only of a personal
um benefit but of course of the
population benefit
professor gupta good to see you this
morning thank you very much for joining
us
uh let's turn our attention now to kevin
courtney of course the joint general
secretary of the national education
union uh kevin great to see you again um
let's start shall we we spoke with the
vaccines minister just a little earlier
on the program and he made it absolutely
clear
that in terms of administering this
vaccination program schools whilst they
may well be the location for some of it
you know educators are not going to be
involved in that process which i i'm
sure is exactly what you and your
members wanted to hear
yeah i mean schools are very used to
being part of this gov of the the
country's childhood vaccination program
so we're used to schools being the site
for that and you know helping out like
volunteers help out at the at the
vaccination centers to a certain degree
making sure the children are there on
time etc but we're not the medical
experts so
it's education staff aren't putting jabs
in arms
good good but
and yet
we have already seen anecdotal reports
of schools being contacted by lawyers
head teachers having messages left on
the answer phone i mean like it or not
it does feel like teachers are going to
be even without a level of involvement
that someone assumed was going to be the
case they will be in the firing line on
this
yeah i mean there are some like
anti-vaxxers who are
very annoyed about this government
decision they've been to our union
headquarters protesting about us having
a
anything to do with it at all and
they'll do that around some schools as
well it's really important that we
protect schools who are just taking the
government decision and doing what they
can do with it
this vaccination of children we're not
medically qualified to know whether it's
how can we know whether it's medically
the right thing but if you listen to
what the scientists are saying you've
just had ravi gupta on or but even if
you listen to jcvi
they said there was a net medical
benefit they said it was small but it
was a net benefit and then the chief
medical officers have looked at the
impact on education disruption which has
been really large in our country i think
that's because we've got big very big
class sizes very hard to stop the virus
spreading so we've had lots of
disruption
if this vaccination can help reduce that
disruption that's a very good thing for
our young people they're not if they're
at home they're not just missing class
time they're also missing time in the
playground they're missing their
swimming lessons they're missing the art
so reducing that disruption is is
important if we can and there is still a
lot of disruption in schools in scotland
at the moment we might be heading into
that in england as well
kevin what what is your understanding of
whether or not schools will will have
the the right or whether they will be
compelled to set up a kind of a two-tier
system there will be some children who
are unvaccinated there will be children
who are vaccinated what would the rules
be about going on school trips or or
class outings of some kind where you
have that mixture of vaccinated and
unvaccinated
well we aren't anticipating that there
will be any such two-tier system between
children who where parents have decided
to vaccinate and children where parents
have decided not to vaccinate we're not
anticipating any such two-tier system i
think schools wouldn't be capable of
operating such a two-tier system
anyway but there's no sign that
government is suggesting that so i think
that's not the issue
but
what we need government to do is to help
us with the public health messaging and
it's also clear from the chief medical
officers that they don't think that
vaccination
is the silver bullet that will stop
disruption of education so we think the
government should still be pressing on
with getting out the co2 monitors
checking ventilation in classrooms maybe
putting hepa filter filtration in those
sorts of steps if we need to going back
to mask wearing as well there are other
steps that can be put in place
to try and stop the virus spreading in
schools
kevin courtney good to see you again
thanks for joining us on the program
now the african country of gabon is
asking the international community for
money in return for protecting some of
the world's most environmentally
important rainforest as oil becomes
scarcer timber has increasing value our
climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter reports now from gabor
we're in gabon on the west coast of
central africa at the invitation of its
government
they are flying us deep into the jungle
the aim to help us understand more about
one of the most forested nations on the
planet
from above the canopy you get a real
sense of the sheer scale of this forest
stretching for hundreds of miles in
every direction and covering nearly 90
of gabon it's part of the congo basin
rainforest which is such an important
ecosystem it's known as the lungs of
africa
gabon has been able to afford to leave
this jungle alone because it's an
oil-rich nation
but prices are plummeting production
dwindling and so that's about to change
you have to read the trees this is the
akumi tree
lee white is the country's british-born
environment minister
sixty percent of our economy is going to
disappear in the next 20 years
as as oil revenues disappear we have to
replace
um
those revenues with something else
that's something else is the forest
gabon wants the international community
to pay it for careful conservation or
risk deforestation for logging and
agriculture
i think it would be very difficult
to maintain for us
long term
without a real partnership
between
developed and developing countries and
without
a business model an economic model that
makes rainforest valuable for the people
that that live in them
firstly we are looking for
forest elephants here we have two
species of elephants we have a savannah
and the forest elephant
degrading the forest would put one of
the most bio-diverse regions on the
planet at risk
in lope national park we see just some
of the wildlife that lives here
a family of chimps crossing the savannah
and later forest elephants
more than 50 000 of them live in gabon
60
of the world's population
but even here climate change is having
an impact warmer temperatures reducing
fruit growth on trees pushing the
elephants into villages
that is
uh the big problem in gabon
every day there are interplantation to
eat the plants like cassava everything
which
the woman plant
that night evidence on our doorstep of
the problem a group of 12 foraging near
our lodge
as climate change intensifies so does
the fragility and importance of this
ecosystem
gabon is one of the few countries on
earth that absorbs more carbon than it
emits it's why this whole region is
crucial to the battle against climate
change and why what happens here will
matter far beyond national borders
this is the strength of gabon's
negotiating position at the cop 26 u.n
climate summit later this year
tongi gahuma bakali is the man making
the argument for a new carbon market
that rewards conservation
because of the need to become emerging
countries all tropical countries in the
world lose their forest
it's a fact our forest is still
stunned the tree are still the same so
now
help us
to
to to not become like other tropical
countries
gabon is at a crossroads
trying to make an environmental asset
profitable without destroying it a model
for the future but only if the rest of
the world agrees
hannah thomas peter sky news in gabon
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment it's bad
for our health too
[Music]
it will be a rather cloudy start with
outbreaks of rain especially in the
south heavy and possibly thundery rain
will move northwards over england with a
mix of bright skies and showers
elsewhere it'd be rather muggy in the
south
the rain will eventually clear to the
north sea later
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high the cloudy and rather wet
conditions will help keep air pollution
levels low throughout today
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
i don't know a lawyer for prince andrew
has appeared in a pre-trial hearing in
new york to dismiss sexual assault
claims against the duke as baseless
unviable and potentially unlawful
virginia dufrese has launched a civil
lawsuit accusing him of sexual assault
joining us now john arnold senior writer
for the sunday times who himself
conducted a series of interviews at with
the duke of york back in 2017. i'm
really good to see you this morning john
um obviously both of us being mindful of
the the legal constraints around the
reporting of cases such as this i wonder
what you make of the way in which the
prince's legal team appears to be trying
to deal with this
we're entering a new chapter you may
remember last time i was talking on this
program i was discussing we were
discussing about how
the court case in america could present
some opportunities for the duke well
you're seeing them try to take those
opportunities now you're seeing them get
on the front foot andrew if he's going
to have any role in public life going
forward which is what he wants is going
to have to get rid of this case he's
going to make this case go away
and the way they're clearly going to try
and do it
is in two stages one is they're going to
try and delay it we saw the arguments
yesterday about whether the papers have
been served properly on the duke that's
a delaying tactic you saw another more
bowl down a strand to the the strategy
which is to try and strike the case out
altogether you'll have seen in court
yesterday lawyers for the duke arguing
that
a previous legal agreement between
virginia dufrey and jeffrey epstein
who's accused of trafficking her
trafficking her to the duke um means
that she can't take legal action over
any other in any other cases in the
future so this this case is baseless so
really it's a new chapter it's a
two-pronged approach one is delay the
other is try and strike out
um of course the the the prince denies
all of the allegations that that are
made against him but but in reputational
terms and of course his relationship
with jeffrey epstein you know brought
some very difficult questions right to
the door of buckingham palace
in reputational terms can the palace can
the prince continue to try to deal with
this situation almost at arm's length in
the way in which they're doing
not really
no they they they they have to get
involved they are getting involved
actually that's what you saw yesterday
they are trying to get involved they're
going to get into this thing and they're
going to try and get rid of it that's
that's the only option that the prince
has and the only way back to any kind of
role in public life his brother the
future king charles has made this
abundantly clear with such serious
allegations
hanging over him litigation court cases
he can't have any public role that means
he the duke knows he has to get rid of
this case he has to put it to one side
make it go away and he's hired a much
much much more proactive aggressive
legal team to try and do those two
things i mentioned just now one is push
it away and delay whilst
creating an opportunity making time to
try and strike it out in other ways the
game here if it is a game is get rid of
this court case
whilst the u.s legal system is often
characterized as being able to protect
the interests of those who have the
money who have the the the the the
contacts and the people like jeffrey
epstein and prince andrew have at the
same time judges do tend there to push
back against people trying to avoid uh
any kind of judicial oversight
yes i i don't think anyone is going to
get any special favors from the judge in
this case or any anyone from uh the
american american side i think they
regard this as
uh as they rightly should do an
extremely serious matter and it doesn't
matter who the uh the people involved in
the case are they will all be treated
absolutely the same uh this will be done
by the book the judge has made that
absolutely clear i suspect the the
argument over the serving of the papers
whether the duke was served with the
legal documents correctly will be dealt
with relatively swiftly he will be
served with the papers and then there'll
be another hearing next month when we uh
we see where the the duke's lawyers are
able to try and strike out the case as
they as they hope so no i don't think
anyone is going to get any special
treatment here at all
ah well certainly there is uh plenty of
running in both this case and indeed the
reputational damage that has been done
to the royal family um just ten seconds
if you can
can the royal family make it back from
this in terms of the pr disaster that
it's been
if the duke strikes out this case that's
the key if this case is hanging around
if that photograph is hanging around
alongside the case of the duke and
virginia to three together there's no
way back for him he's got he's got to
get this case off the table
john elijah good to see you thanks very
much for joining us again on the program
stay where you are after the break we'll
be hearing from labour on exactly what
they're looking for in the government's
upcoming winter plan announcement that's
next
[Music]